esta es la instalación nuclear que está
en el centro de las últimas tensiones
latentes entre irán e israel la planta
de enriquecimiento de natanz se
encuentra en el desierto en la provincia
central de isfahán y el domingo se quedó
sin electricidad
las autoridades iraníes describieron el
incidente como un acto de terrorismo
nuclear y juraron represalias
el régimen sionista' con esta acción
intentó vengarse del pueblo de irán
entre gómez en sa pero por su paciencia
y sabiduría cuando se trata del
levantamiento de las sanciones la
respuesta de irán será la venganza
contra el régimen sionista' en el
momento y lugar adecuados
desde el incidente los medios de
comunicación de israel han informado
constantemente de un devastador ciber
ataque orquestado por el país
funcionarios locales no confirmaron ni
negaron los hechos pero el primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu acudió a la
prensa para reafirmar su posición sobre
irán mi política como primer ministro de
israel es clara nunca permitiré que irán
obtenga la capacidad nuclear para llevar
a cabo su objetivo genocida de eliminar
a israel e israel continuará
defendiéndose de la agresión y el
terrorismo de irán
si alguna vez se confirma está
ciertamente no sería la primera vez que
tel aviv intenta sabotear el programa
nuclear de teherán según funcionarios
actuales o retirados como el ex general
israelí meír dagán ha habido una campaña
de asesinatos selectivos de científicos
nucleares iraníes los israelíes han
estado participando en una guerra en la
sombra contraerán durante muchos muchos
años para evitar que irán avance en su
programa nuclear les están diciendo esto
a los estadounidenses no tienes que
aliviar las sanciones puede simplemente
atacar a sus científicos puede
simplemente atacar sus instalaciones el
incidente se produce un día después de
que irán a presentar a centrifugadoras
avanzadas para enriquecer uranio un
componente clave para las armas
nucleares en lo que llama el día
nacional nuclear
[Música]
el evento estuvo marcado por este
homenaje musical también coincide con la
reanudación de las negociaciones entre
teherán y la comunidad internacional
para revivir el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
que según netanyahu israel no estaría
obligado a cumplir